intense moments at this opposition party
headquarters in Kinshasa some
presidential candidates have rallied
their supporters to reject election
results which are being tallied by the
Electoral
commission police quarter off the area a
few young men want to Stage a march on
the
streets no one is above the law we
informed authorities about the protest
that is why the police are supposed to
be here to protect if they are here to
attack us we will resist and defend
ourselves this has been going on for a
while police have been trying to uh
arrest some of the protesters who are in
that building it's a party headquarters
of Martin fulu a presidential
candidate several people including
police officers are injured in the
confrontations
finally this man comes out of the
building waving a white flag he has a
message for the police the organizers
wared a truce so they can take the
injured to hospital Martin fulu has been
inside the whole time he says Security
Forces used live bullets and this is not
an election anymore we will not accept
the election and will never accept the
result coming from there opposition
supporters say this this is just the
beginning and they won't stop until
their voices are hard Katherine soy aler
kinasa make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer